one of the most popular ways to
cultivate mushrooms indoors is in a
modified plastic bin often referred to
as a monotube in the mushroom community
professional growers will inoculate
their grain spawn using a liquid culture
solution or colonized agar these are
more advanced techniques that we're
going to talk about in a different video
but since i just grow for fun and as a
hobby i've only ever really worked with
spore syringes working with a live
mycelium is going to be a more foolproof
method but that shouldn't intimidate you
from giving this a shot with a spore
syringe as with everything in nature
there's a chance that your spores won't
germinate or successfully colonize the
most crucial part is finding a reliable
spore vendor as well as working with
spawn and substrate that you know is
clean and sterilized
so the spawn of the substrate that i'm
working with is from midwest grow kits
um they do all of the sterilization and
the pasteurization for you so it's
really easy and convenient for me and
i've had great results with their stuff
the spores that i'm working with are
from premiumspores.com but i've also
used spoilerworks.commushrooms.com
and a few different vendors off of
reddit and etsy as well if you need any
recommendations for best chances of
success you are going to need your
inoculation area to be as sterile as
possible there are a few different ways
that you could do this like you could
build a still air box or use the oven
door method i am just using
open air in this video which is not the
best way to do it um but
i
locked out all my pets and any people 24
hours before i wanted to start doing
this um i also closed all the vents all
the windows and picked an area that has
just very little foot traffic in there
to begin with
and then before i started i wiped down
all of my working surfaces with 70
isopropyl alcohol about five to ten
minutes beforehand all right so now that
we got all of that out of the way it's
time to get started so get out your
spawn bags and your sports syringe
you're also going to want a mask gloves
and plenty of alcohol wipes as well as a
lighter for a little later on each spawn
bag is sealed with a clear piece of tape
a few inches above the white filter
patch so very carefully you're going to
try to separate the tape from the bottom
of the bag and make a little cut it
should be pretty easy to come undone
after this we might also have to make a
little cut on the other side as well so
after you get it unrolled you want to
try to get a little bit of space between
the grains in the bag so that you don't
pierce through the plastic when you
inoculate next i'm going to wipe down my
gloves with the alcohol wipes before i
start handling my spore syringe
once those are dry you can grab your
spore syringe and shake it around to
break up any clumps that may be in there
and distribute it throughout the
solution
once that looks good you're going to
open up the needle
set that to the side and then twist the
cap off of the syringe and then you're
going to twist the needle on in its
place
grab another alcohol wipe and wipe down
the black injection port on the spawn
bag and let it dry for about 15 seconds
so take the plastic covering off of the
needle grab the side of the spawn bag
for some stability and then insert the
syringe through the injection port
you're going to inoculate three to five
cc's in total per bag you want to try to
disperse the spores evenly across the
top of the bag before moving along to
the sides in the center of the grains
when you do this you're exposing more
grains to the spore solution which will
help prevent any excess moisture from
pooling at the bottom
which in turn will make colonization a
lot easier kind of hard to film and
inoculate simultaneously so i did inject
a little bit more spore solution than i
was supposed to but it's all right
everything is fine before you inoculate
the second bag be sure to sterilize the
needle with the flame for a few seconds
then wipe down the needle with an
alcohol wipe again and follow the same
steps as you did before
if you're using the green jars it's
basically the same process as the bags
but you're going to be using three to
four cc's of spore solution instead
the same applies to the jars just make
sure to disperse the spore solution
throughout the top of the greens before
you move along to the sides
so you're going to need to incubate
these in a warm area for about four to
six weeks ideal temperatures to prevent
any contamination would be between 74
and 78 degrees fahrenheit i've always
stored them in a sealed container like
it's just a random plastic bin but
you can always store them just on a
shelf maybe above the fridge or
in a closet
just any area that's undisturbed and
warm
if you are keeping them in a sealed
container you can maintain the co2
levels by opening up the lid every week
or so
and here's a little look at my grain
spawn over a course of five weeks
here's a classic example of
contamination in a spawn bag right away
you can notice the bright discoloration
as well as the difference in texture it
looks more chalky and almost dusty like
this is exactly why sterile environment
is so important i was just inoculating
these bags in an open air large room
and i forgot to close the vent that day
so
oopsies
all right so that wraps up part one stay
tuned for part two which is coming soon
and also be sure to like and subscribe
as well as comment on some other
mushroom teams you'd like me to cover
thanks for watching